meet Wesley he likes carrots he spends
most of his time sunbathing and life is
best when he can actually see for
Wesley's owner and wsj executive
producer Adam Beneke now is past the
time when he normally take Wesley to the
groomer this is browser Hey with many
groomers closed owners are looking at
scruffy pups he basically just looks
like a ball of hair walking in the
street and now it's up to their owners
sort of
that's where Gary angel comes in yes yes
I do we have dogs he runs my two dogs
training and grooming business in New
York I've been grooming now for probably
18 years honestly you can a lot can go
wrong with dog grooming if you don't
know what you're doing he's here to
guide us through how to keep these dogs
and your pup groomed at home I you know
emphasize extreme caution when you're
doing anything that I'm talking about
here browser how do you feel about your
hair right now
step one run your hands through your
dog's coat what you're looking for is
any clumps of hair any matting that's to
you know to get a basic idea of what
kind of shape the coat is in here it's a
little bit of a knot they can cause
discomfort and in in cases where they're
not taking care of you know you can get
you know skin issues underneath the mass
yes they just like hell on the paw yeah
not you buddy you very cute step to trim
your dog you're gonna need your call
because you want to comb the area out
you know and away from the skin and then
what I use our little small tip baby
scissors and don't use kitchen scissors
what you want to do with the visor is
you want to start about here
in cold wet forward like bangs the visor
will overhang the eyes and then what you
have the visor down you just take your
scissors and you you would just very
carefully just trim around once you trim
it and you can see the dog's eyes stop
can you see can you see the camera with
the paws what you want to do is you want
to have the paw flat flat on the ground
and you just want to kind of follow the
shape of the foot you know when you do
it like this the nails will help to keep
it away from the foot itself much better
step 3 cleaning the ears you know you
can use a cotton ball you can even use a
q-tip on smaller ear dogs if you have a
local pet store near you see if they
have an ear cleaner in a pinch and I've
used it many many times hydrogen
peroxide get the q-tip on one and get it
wet with you know your ear cleaner your
hydrogen peroxide and go around the
outside of the ear and a little bit on
the inside of the ear and then go back
in and wipe around again once you've
done you're done cleaning the ear do you
want to take some cotton and you want to
stuff it in the dog's ears to try to
keep the water out while you're washing
your dog step four is calming
you know you take your steel comb and
what you want to do you want to follow
the grain of the dog's hair and if you
hit snags what I will do is I will put
my fingers in between the skin and the
snag and and try to slightly tease it
out and you're not just you know yanking
on the dog's hair look at that [ __ ]
coat step 5
put your dog in the tub so what you want
to do is you want to use warm water you
don't want hot water on your dog you
want to thoroughly wet your dog make
sure your dog is wet to the skin you put
the shampoo on and and massage it in and
work it in really well please do not use
human shampoo use an all-natural dog
shampoo I think I have full coverage
then what you want to do is you want to
rinse your dog when the water starts
running clear then everything is out
step 6
dry now I'll be honest with you when
you're drying your dog at home you're
probably not going to get 100% dry you
wanted to try to dry them as much as you
can with with a hair dryer you want to
use it on cool or low heat and while
you're drying just a nice slow
back-and-forth
and if you can make a starburst pattern
in your dog's quote because then the
hair won't tangle up as you're drying it
step 7
throw a puppy party whenever you tell
your dog it was wonderful it was
magnificent and just make a fuss over
them say oh good baby oh what a good
baby didn't let him know that you know
grooming is it you know horrible
experience oh boy that wasn't so bad was
it put up with it and this is what you
get you get you know a puppy party you
think you're going to the groomer